before I get into some of the more
lesser known characters in the division
I want to make sure I've covered the
main parts of the storyline first
as most of these individuals line up
with the main story in one way or
another and if you're anything like me
you've spent so many hundreds of hours
obsessing over gear and builds that
you've long since forgotten the full
detail of the main storyline so for the
next couple of videos I'll be talking
about things you may already know but
bear with me we'll be getting into the
cool stuff soon the cleaners
misunderstood good guys or straight-up
evil villains running amuck on the
streets of Manhattan well actually
they're a bit of both the cleaners
originated as the blue-collar workers of
New York City janitors sanitation
garbage men electricians construction
workers truck drivers these are the
people that the government originally
asked to assist in saving the city
through transport digging of mass graves
and eventually the construction of the
wall that would surround the quarantine
zone these are the groups that continue
to support the civil services when the
city infrastructure was breaking down
unfortunately these are also some of the
people that were left behind when the
JTF and government pulled out of the
dark zone and much like the first wave
division agents these men were left
feeling betrayed and abandoned it was at
this point that an individual by the
name of Joe Farrow steps up and
organizes these abandoned workers into a
force that would do what was needed to
contain the virus and restore order to
the streets of New York City before the
outbreak Joe Farrow lived and worked in
Manhattan with his wife as a sanitation
worker it was a family orientated man a
devout husband and he cared deeply for
his niece Farrah was always particularly
vocal about his opinions and frequently
called into live radio broadcasts to
share his point of view with the
American public when the dollar flu
outbreak first hit fair his wife was one
of the first victims to become infected
and shortly after succumbed to the virus
after the spheres mindset towards the
country and its government started to
change
he calls into a radio broadcaster
shira's opinion we have an old joke
affair oh hey yo what's it take on a
della flu I think this really shows how
vulnerable this country is I mean how
stupid you have to be not to go to the
hospital when you're sick as a dog
we got people going to work to the
supermarket even though the goddamn
movies infecting thousands of other
people are a pure ignorant I'm telling
you this is gonna blow up big time just
because most people are too damn stupid
to realize what's going on there's no
one with the balls not the government
not nobody and the brains to do what's
got to be done to keep this from
spreading sorry to cut you off there gel
tape is always where you're thought as
more and more people started to get
infected and more and more bodies
started lining the streets
Vera's mental state continued to slide -
with his wife now dead he continues to
think that the government isn't doing
anything to stop the virus his thoughts
are that no one else is brave enough to
do anything about it with all his faith
in the government lost he takes the
matters into his own hands he assembles
the men and woman who worked alongside
the JTF in the government before they
left he proceeds to tell them that there
is now only one way to stop the virus
burn it burn all of it burn every trace
of it and thus the cleaners were born
unlike the other factions the cleaners
were assembled with the intentions of
doing good Farris strongly believes that
they are the true heroes fighting
against the virus on the frontlines he's
constantly stating that they're the ones
leaving everything they had behind just
so they can stay in New York and do what
has to be done because of his wife
Pharaoh has seen what the virus can do
firsthand and he is convinced that there
is no saving people once they're
infected given that the government has
fled the quarantine zone he decides that
it's up to him and the cleaners to stop
the virus and get control back of the
city and that there is no one else brave
enough to take the necessary steps to
stop this thing once and for all not
only is he convinced that they're the
good guys but he continues to convince
others to his followers hold a lot of
respect for him because of commitment
and dedication to his goals
[Music]
through Firoz guidance the cleaners
weapon of choice is fire fire is the
ultimate cleaning tool so everything
that's come in contact with the virus
must burn from parts and pieces they
find lying around they create their
signature weapon the flamethrower
they develop a recipe for napalm and
they construct their own hazmat suits
their goal purify the city by burning
away impurities and corruption the
cleaners are devoted to the job and if
anyone gets in their way
they're part of the problem and a
swiftly dealt to they travel from area
to area cleansing the streets if there
is any evidence of contamination they
won't hesitate and sitting ablaze cars
or even buildings full of people as in
their eyes the second already dead and
they're doing humanity a favor by
stopping the spread of the virus however
there are a couple of problems with this
method of purifying and cleansing of the
virus firstly the cleaners can't really
tell if people are infected there no
doctors they're just looking out for the
smallest thing that could be a sign
feeling a little rundown and showing
signs of fatigue too bad better safe
than sorry and secondly as JTF
neurologist jessica kendall mentions
their methods are actually making the
situation far worse from a neurologist
point of view the goal of wiping of the
virus by burning everything in sight
actually severely Enders any efforts
towards creating a vaccine to help keep
it from spreading the second wave
division agents first encounter the
cleaners in an underground subway
network the cleaners were tasked with
purifying the area by burning everything
in everyone there although their goal
was to retrieve Paul Rhoads the division
agents stopped the cleaners from
achieving their task and quickly
eliminate them from the site the
cleaners then attack the Hudson refugee
camp but again
the division agents and the JTF managed
to stop them before the entire site is
put up in flames from the information
gathered the division identified the
source of the virus
Able's department store agents were sent
forth to gather some samples of the
original affected dollar bills but the
cleaners were already there sitting the
entire mall ablaze
okay agent you're looking for any bills
our pal Amherst used to spread his
original virus strain we know he used
Abel's as one of his primary launching
pads so with any luck there should be
plenty of contaminated greenbacks lying
around in there as well as civilians the
store is one of the bigger refugee camps
we've been monitoring not to make a
whole thing out of it but if you don't
find some unmutated virus I can use as a
comp we may as well give up any hope of
creating a vaccine so you know no
pressure but yet again the superior
training and equipment of the shd agents
pushed the cleaners back and we're able
to secure the samples it was at this
point that the division realized that
the hostile faction known as the
cleaners were far more organized than
initially thought and they were not
going anywhere they needed to be dealt
to after the JT have discovered the
cleaners headquarters and that this was
also their source of napalm production
the division agents were sent in to shut
them down as well as putting a stop to
the napalm production the agents also
found Joe Pharaoh himself after a small
conflict the leader of the cleaners was
eventually killed of the division agents
with this source of napalm destroyed and
the leader assassinated the cleaners
were demoralized but regardless the
cleaners continued to push on believing
deeply in the goals of doing what no one
else has the guts to do they showed
their ingenuity by building their own
super weapon the dragon a fire truck no
a literal fire truck with an enormous
flamethrower and flaming more tire
equipped this was to be used to clear
out large areas and buildings more
efficiently allowing them to cover more
ground although well defended this too
was intercepted by the division agents
before it was ever able to be unleashed
into Manhattan after this defeat the
cleaners scattered into smaller groups
around New York City it's unknown who's
leading them at this stage but they have
come to some sort of truce with the
Olympian Rikers as they can be seen
working together in the West Side Pier
although their threat seems to have been
considerably reduced after the loss of
Joe Farrow and the destruction of their
super weapon any remaining cleaners at
this point still seem very much
committed to ferry's goal of burning out
the virus in anyone who stands in their
way
the cleaners were assembled in an
attempt to save the city unfortunately
the misguided methods had them set on a
more brutal genocidal path but it leaves
me wondering one thing regardless of
their methods to the cleaners actually
helped stop the virus from becoming more
widely spread early on yes they almost
stopped a Cure from being developed and
they killed hundreds maybe thousands of
Nonsuch innocents but had they not been
around when the virus was most rampant
with the situation in New York and
potentially the neighboring states being
a much worse state right now so what do
you think are the cleaners the misguided
misunderstood heroes of the special
against the green poison or are they
simply just a bunch of psychopathic
pyromaniacs that were brought together
by a mentally unstable grief-stricken
husband let me know what you think
Cheers
and again thank you yes we thought it to
me how are you kiddo
I'm good mommy and daddy feelin okay
yeah
but we've been sitting out hundred days
Uncle Joe it's booming I bet it is kiddo
hey listen I want to tell you something
you know how sometimes Uncle Joe is on
the radio yeah well it might be that
I'll be on the radio again soon or the
people will talk about me there and they
might say things that aren't true okay
well whatever they may say I want you to
know I want you to remember that then I
only ever wanted you to be safe
everything I'm doing all the good and
bad so you could be safe okay okay yeah
that's my girl gotta go now I love you
[Music]